the objects are clearly not
ET though why do you say they're clearly
not the statement has been made by the
press secretary for Biden who said that
they have no indication that their
extraterrestrial their Air Force
officials that have said the same thing
and they don't behave in any that they
don't demonstrate the kind of behaviors
that we're used to when something is
extraterrestrial uh I don't so I just
and I have sources that have told me uh
also from the intelligence community
that they're not that they're Chinese
basically
um and I think the the bigger issue here
has to do with the geopolitical Dynamics
uh between China and the United States
and there's there's a lot going on
I think behind the scenes around all of
this that
we're not privy to and hopefully over
time more will come out they don't want
to State publicly this is Chinese
because it would cause more of a
conflict than they would like I I you
know I don't know if they're just not
100 certain or if they're yeah there may
be reasons why they don't want to say it
or they want to use this these UFOs as
kind of a cover so they're sort of
hedging it
or they're just not clear and maybe some
of the Congress people feel they've been
left out they want to know more and then
one person says this and somebody else
says that and it's just messy
uh but I think there's you know there's
more that we I'm sure will come out over
time but I just um I feel clear that
these are not we don't have to speculate
that these are some kind of non-human
technology or something I don't I really
don't think that's the case
I'm going to read a comment from Ross
goldthart and I'll put on the screen
because it's fairly wordy I asked them
for a question and he gave me a comment
that's all okay cool you can just
comment on his comments just so people
know he has been really focused on this
and he's brilliant and he's he you know
he's really really uh been monitoring
everything and thinking a lot about it
more than I have so let his comment
carry the day sure there is clearly
dissent between sections of the Pentagon
notably the U.S Air Force and the White
House when National Security adviser
Jake Kirby saw that the dod had publicly
briefed journalists these objects were
likely balloons he clearly knew enough
to directly overrule that assumption
they are not balloons you do not fire
Sidewinder missiles at balloons and
balloons not have the structure clearly
described by the pilots someone tried to
lie to the public and for the first time
in decades the White House has overruled
that lie fascinating right and though
and and all I I mean I agree with Ross
and also the White House has said that
they want to set up their own h agency
to look into this which was kind of a
shock too because we have the the arrow
the Department of Defense entity doing
its job and now suddenly the exact you
know that the president announces that
he wants to set up another task force
so
um yeah it's all these contradictory
issues that are going on at once as Ross
points out and hopefully it's gonna
it'll smooth itself out over time did
you receive a considerable amount of
pushback or reproach from your article
from the 2017-2019 one you mean by like
Skeptics or from the editorial teams at
the New York Times or from your
colleagues or from the broader Community
I'm curious to know where does the
pushback come from and where does the
adulation come from where does the
praise come from
yeah um I mean I think the story was
just so explosive that
um
you know I mean
it changed everything you know so I
don't know I'm sure there are people
that have criticisms of it
um and I know that you know
um
we didn't reference the allsap program
which has upset some people
um
but I don't know it's hard hard for me
to answer like where does criticism come
from where does price come from I mean
it was just like this was sent off like
a cannonball you know reverberated
around the world and I think the focus
was just oh my god look these are real
in the Pentagon studying them